si sufre de prolapso de los órganos
pélvicos o incontinencia de esfuerzo su
médico puede recomendar el uso de un
pesario los músculos del diafragma
pélvico y otros tejidos de soporte
mantienen su vejiga útero
y recto en su lugar si estos músculos y
tejidos se debilitan sus órganos pueden
desplazarse fuera de su posición
correcta lo que resulta en un prolapso
de los órganos pélvicos un pesario es un
dispositivo que puede insertar en su
vagina para sostener y disminuir la
presión sobre su vejiga y otros órganos
pélvicos para introducir un pesario en
forma de anillo con perilla doble lo por
la mitad coloque una pequeña cantidad de
lubricante en el extremo sin perilla
utilicé sus dedos para extender los
labios inserte cuidadosamente el pesario
en la vagina lo más profundo posible
utilice su dedo índice para hacer girar
el extremo con perilla del pesario hacia
arriba usted no debe sentirlo una vez
que éste se encuentra en la posición
correcta es posible que deba intentar
varios tamaños y estilos para asegurar
un ajuste adecuado ya que incluso el
pesar yo de mejor ajuste puede causar
irritación su médico la revisará cada
tres a seis meses